Hi, baby boy.
Talking to the fishes, you would be so different.
Special.
We're connected to the land and the sea.
I can't wait to introduce you
to all the majestic creatures on our planet.
Show you how awesome this world can be.
Yeah.
You and me.
I'm going to curl up with me.
Even if I have to make a deal with the devil to do it.
Free me from my press
and all my power will be yours.
The key to this prison is the royal bloodline itself.
He needs us.
We're the end of the bloodline.
But we're not.
Yeah,
And to junior,
he must be stopped.
I'm this for you.
Destroy everything he holds dear.
You are bloody
content.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
They dropped a brand new Aquaman 2
The Lost Kingdom Trailer.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter Eggs here.
Jason Momoa has also talked about this being, like,
the last time that he will play the Aquaman character,
but he will be back in future.
DC movies under James Gunn's DCU.
Don't worry, we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
This is what Jason Momoa said about this
being like the last time that he's
going to play his version of the Snyder's
Justice League version of Aquaman.
it true this might be the last one
or could there be a third Aquaman?
I mean, it's things have happened before,
this is kind of like the end of this,
this DC, DC universe.
will always be a place for me.
A DC they were there. Will Right.
There's like,
like, yeah.
You know, we like you.
when he says there'll always be a place for him at DC,
he's talking about coming back.
Most of us believe that's going to be
is the Lobo character
just because of everything that he's said previously?
I've done a couple of Lobo videos before this.
He's had a couple of interviews
where he talked about playing other characters,
quote unquote, like winking at the camera.
there was a lot of scuttlebutt behind the scenes
about him coming back as a version of Lobo,
but we're not totally sure on which movie
that's going to be.
And that might wind up being Superman
Woman of Tomorrow, like some other cosmic based movie.
But I'm not expecting it to be in Superman Legacy.
They just feels like it's a little too soon.
I'll talk more about that later in the video.
Just getting to the actual footage,
starting at the beginning of the trailer footage,
he's talking to Aqua Baby. That's right.
His name is Aqua Baby.
In the comics,
although it's technically Arthur Curry Jr.
when he's talking about how the two of them are special
they're both connected to the land and the sea.
They should that aqua baby here
can actually talk to Marine life
but the way they explain things in the DCU here
is that the high born atlanteans
can breathe on land and in water.
So that's
why his brother Ocean Master, can breathe above water.
But like the normal atlanteans here
that are sitting around this arena here can't
that's why
some of them have to wear special suits out of water
This is a shot of Aquaman Ocean master
and an octopus with them.
it looks like there's an octopus with them
when he breaks them out of that desert prison.
Inside the kingdom of the desert is basically So
just seems like this is on their way back to Atlantis.
they said it the whole black manta plot
during the movie the idea is that he finds
the black trident that belonged to Mongo,
who is from the comics ruling over Necrosis.
which is basically like the lost
seventh Kingdom of Atlantis In the comics,
it was phased into a different dimension and like
it would crossover with our dimension occasionally.
during the events of this movie,
they might just say that it was buried inside
the Arctic in sealed using Atlantean royal blood
Because it seems like Mongo,
who's played by Pilou Abzug from Game of Thrones,
he played Euron Greyjoy.
So kind of appropriate
that he's playing Nicholas in this movie.
he makes a bargain with black manta
to give him all of his power,
like the power of the black trident here,
which is basically raising the dead back to life.
this green fire also seems like it consumes everything
and also turns it into other undead creatures.
he says he'll give him the power
to destroy Aquaman in exchange for freeing him in.
In order to do that,
he needs the blood of Atlantean hybrids,
like part of the royal family,
which is why he goes for Aquaman's son, Aqua Baby.
But here's the thing.
And this sort of gets back to the whole idea
that this is going to be like the very final DCU movie
unless somebody leaks the bad girl movie,
even though technically I think that was meant
to be kind of in its own little universe.
James Wan, the director
mostly known for his horror movies.
I think they actually want to end on a more hopeful
note because this is like the very final DCU movie.
and killing Aqua Baby during the movie,
even though it did happen in the comics,
just feels like it would be this movie going
a little too hard they don't want to go out like that.
So that's why during the trailer,
they're making it seem like his father gets killed
by Black Manta when he comes to steal Aqua Baby.
the only other people in the movie
that I would say on the chopping block, like they could
potentially be killed would be his mother,
because it says that he needs royal blood.
but during the trailer, Black Man
two basically says that he'll do whatever it takes
to gain the power to kill, to destroy Aquaman
and everything that he loves,
even if it costs him
like even though there's collateral damage,
which basically sets up the idea that he's
going to lose control of Mongo in his army here
if he didn't see the Marvels movie,
they actually kind of had a twist like that with the
two Miss Marvel Bengals.
Like DA been the main villain of that movie,
got control of both Bengals,
but it was too much power for her.
so don't feel like it's a spoiler to say
because the movie's been out for a while
and it was in all the trailers.
Basically, she wasn't trying to absorb too much power.
She tried to use too much power in it destroyed her,
which is kind of like
somebody using the infinity gantlet
who wasn't powerful enough to actually wielded
it looks like something similar might wind up
befalling black manta
like some similar type of fate
where the power's too much for him,
we get a bunch more footage of Mongo
if that's going to be his name in the movie.
I'm just calling him that
because that was his name in the comics
these seem like scenes from flashbacks to ancient
Atlantis in him fighting King Atlan with Atlantis
was still above water there are a bunch of flashbacks
in the previous trailers.
So I think we're just going to get some more context
about who he is, where his power comes from
and why it's so dangerous
and why at land locked him in this prison in the past.
And it just seems like black manta is successful
in getting some kind of royal blood,
in unlocking his power and unleashing him in this
this giant battle against Atlantis.
that's probably what their big third act
is going to wind up being.
but this trailer really, really wants to make you think
that they're going to kill the aqua
baby were the last of the bloodline.
Wait, no, no, we're not.
There's one more, my son. Notice here.
When Aquaman says he's coming for him,
he's probably talking about Nicholas and Black Manta.
But it also looks like ORM is wielding
the black trident behind him, like that green flame.
this is a huge battle
between him and Black Manta in this place here, too.
So if ORM has the black trident,
that means that they got it from Black Manta.
So either he killed black manta or something
happened to him for them to get it from him,
but I think the idea is that Black
Manta is just the villain for most of the movie.
And then Mongo winds up being like
the real main villain at the end of the film.
there's a very quick shot of Randall Parks, Dr.
Steven Shin, who is working with Black Panther
at the end of the first Aquaman movie.
It seems like he's reluctantly helping him
find the lost Kingdom so that he can get that Trident.
they weren't totally clear on what his beef with
Aquaman was like.
Why is he helping Black Manta if he's a villain?
I think part of the idea
is that the rest of the scientific world
considered him crazy for believing that Atlantis exists
and all these atlanteans
there's another trailer
they release with a bunch of different battles, like a
couple of the different major battles in the film
I think part of the idea in the movie
is that things pick up and they just show
what's happened with him since his son was born, him
just getting used to being a father
and being the king of Atlantis.
those are a couple minor battles
at the beginning of the film with him just taking down
a bunch of random thugs around the ocean,
cleaning up the ocean, so to speak.
that I think the idea is that Black Manta
finds the Trident attacks Atlantis,
and then he realizes that he needs more help
Then he goes to free.
Or from the kingdom of the deserters
where the prison has been holding him.
because ORM understands
all the lore behind Mongo, the lost
kingdom in everything that they need to defeat
black Manta in Mongo.
part of the idea with Ocean Master is that
he was raised with the idea that he would be king.
So like he got all these important lessons
about the history of their culture,
the history of Atlantis
that Aquaman doesn't really know anything about.
So I think if Ocean Master winds up
surviving this movie, even though there is no intention
to do Aquaman three, the idea is that going forward,
that ocean master would start to serve.
Aquaman is sort of his new version of Voca
like serve the role that Voco used to serve.
so. I think part of the idea is that DC
next year has some of the spinoff TV
shows coming to HBO,
like the Batman HBO show with The Penguin, James Gunn
tease more information about the Green Lantern HBO show
they're working on right now.
generally, though,
the Batman HBO series is like the big thing
that's coming from DC next year
and not a whole lot of movie stuff.
Like it's kind of an off year for them
because the next big movie is Superman Legacy,
which is the official beginning of James
Gunn's era of the DCU.
it is no coincidence that Marvel is now kind
of taking the same tactic
where they're pulling way back
like the delayed a bunch of their movies,
all except for Deadpool three next year until 2025.
Marvel on their side of things will have
a couple TV series coming to Disney plus during 2024.
But But like DC they're kind of taking a year off,
so to speak, just to ramp up the quality,
like take the extra time,
extra care to make their 2025 movies that much better.
which I think is actually going to pay off for both
Marvel and DC like on both sides of the aisle here.
generally a lot of the issues
that came up with the movies that came out
the last couple of years, people
complaining about fatigue, about quality control,
about too much coming out too soon, too fast,
that was all a result of like the pandemic
era filmmaking where they were just trying
to get stuff out the door as fast as possible.
Now, that isn't really an issue to them.
So they're pulling way, way back.
so if 2024 feels kind of like an off like a rest year
for comic book superhero movies, that's why
there's still a couple coming out
and we have the TV series, but generally
it will feel like kind of an off year for comic
book movies.
but overall, whatever winds up happening
with the Aquaman movie, like good or bad,
I am excited to see Jason Momoa
come back as a version of Lobo.
It does feel like he could knock that out of the park.
He was born to play a character like Lobo.
if there's any Easter eggs
that you spotted in the footage that he didn't talk
about in the video or my previous Aquaman videos,
just write them below in the comments.
Or if you have any questions about what's going on
just in general with all the DC movies.
I just did a Superman Legacy preview video.
Click here to learn about that
and here's my Loki Season 3 teaser video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!